[Music]
good morning everyone and how's it going
and happy Monday we are back with some
gamespot live action Persia here and
Nick Sherman is joining us because we're
gonna be playing the Final Fantasy 7
remake demo that is live now on the
PlayStation Store so if you guys did not
know you can hop on that it's absolutely
free and yeah we've kind of been all
waiting for it for so long and we're
finally getting a taste and for people
who haven't been able to go to e3 s and
of the sort we're a little bit of the
demo has been available we now get to
try it out yes and I was gonna play it
this morning with it you invited me to
do this if you guys don't know Nick is
like the Final Fantasy 7 professional I
mean I only had the honour of playing
Final Fantasy the original like this
past year in 2019 but when I was playing
it at my desk like Nick would always
walk by and be like oh yeah that boss
yeah I remember that
oh I beat him first try so demons gate
exactly so had to bring Nick on today so
he can witness this his first
run-through I thought I played it
earlier I couldn't help myself but it's
really really good and I'm actually
super excited to get your reaction on it
considering you are like a pro diehard
fan right here so I'm looking forward to
it everyone in the chat thank you so
much for joining us I will be reading
your comments so make sure you're
chatting with us while we play and
whenever you're ready Nick how's the
volume for you you want to be more in
the
atmosphere probably to start out with
ideally both when I was at e3 I did try
out the classic mode and the the new
updated setting they have it's like half
real-time half action
yeah and I did see the trailer for this
already but definitely let's watch it
again
yes always I see you guys in the chat
welcome back a car to locate quests
Matthew Gary Han see little Jonathan so
so where did you end up leaving us I had
when I was playing the original I left
off a little bit past when I fought like
the water monster I'm like on a beach in
jounin yes
yes it was really fun which made playing
this like really really enjoyable
I will admit one of the things I've been
looking forward to the most is seeing
the updated soundtrack that they make
for this game cuz I know the original by
heart
[Music]
timeless classic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
these poor guys instant goosebumps says
Michael Machado yeah this is available
now you guys on the PS Store
[Music]
heard you down here murder
that dramatic intro we love it
[Music]
seamless who goes there
I'm actually not sure if it's coming out
on PC at the same time as the ps4
release you're coming with us nice and
easy
don't think though
I think it's Auto automatically
is about a 45 minute demo you guys so we
may run through its life
[Music]
looks like they modeled it after a
subway system yeah go ahead
enough of this here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I like this part anything you can
interact with you just run up to it
before you know big drop the weapon you
got this yeah what he said
[Music]
you're coming with us surrounded
[Music]
try harder
[Music]
now that
yeah I definitely do get a little bit
Kingdom Hearts vibes with this which I
love I love music
yeah
[Music]
so what soldier boy steel is he one of
us now he's got balls this what was his
name again cloud cloud strife right and
he isn't a soldier anymore
still he's a professional unlike the
rest of us I'm glad to have him this is
a one-time gig when it's done we're done
I just love that Jesse is just thirsting
after clubs oh I know he seems like real
joy look at ya
all right hopefully that works
come on nobody do something this crazy
just for money they may not think you're
a true believer but you know what I
think that interested
it's like they picked all of his
Butthead responses from the ones that
you could pick like no the mean ones the
further you get the story you can kind
of make cloud like you better be worth
the money mark every last Gil where it
kinds of rough out here
oh what a classic scene
I really hope they recreate on this Oh
super sure they will
jerem boy
[Music]
this dog oh just doing his job
looks like your next
[Music]
it not
[Music]
[Music]
yeah that's a good question
who hasn't played the first like the
original Final Fantasy's we've got
company
I kind of like that a lot of games
nowadays are making things more friendly
for the fan - or the players who have
never played parts of the series like
you've seen it's checking ball khakkhara
they're like revisiting the entire lore
from the start which is really fun as
somebody who like never got to watch it
as it was coming out of the kids and now
with Hannah Montana box-t says never get
final fantasy a try so this remake I
feel I can't not give it a try
exactly there's always somebody upset
that you never played it before you know
it's one of those games
took you long enough
oh yeah I should move the cameras and to
write because our little hug there on
the bottom left one second
[Music]
all right yes there we go camera is
officially out of the way right Akash
where da go super Ben what up says
greetings from Scotland well thank you
for tuning in always cool see who's
tuning in from around the world
what a random legacy yes alright Nick so
early first impressions Ritchie's gotta
know it's you know it's different the
way I approach it is the you know the
originals always no matter how this
turns out I'm always gonna have that so
I'm going to approach this
[Music]
an updated version
I knew with the combat that's fine how
much nostalgia do you feel even though
the mechanics are totally different like
in the little cutscenes is it mostly
where it lies well they've nailed it
right like as I was I pointed out
earlier that the cut seams so I think
stamp scared to bite the hand that fed
him or is he a loyal dog have it your
way much anything we can do this with
you oh we can do this without his
presence different reactors different
layout depends when it was built to go
to it's never seen one like this but
I'll manage factors into the story and
you know the beginning of the game but
not so much and since he's the overall
antagonist of the game they gotta do a
lot more to good
chase says hello from Arizona account
weeps plea well we can't wait for you to
play like everyone's been waiting so
long now I'm like everyone I know that
was waiting for it I messaged him today
did you know yet imagine a Chrono
Trigger remake like this see the way
things are I would not be surprised to
see every mate of every single class
Nikki oh Jesus straight up gave you the
food pretty cool maybe in like let's go
25 more years will have the Final
Fantasy 7 remake remade Barrett's tired
of her 13 you can get us the passcodes
hey do you know what else that command
will talk to us but what can you do
we're good so Julio and I have made a
funny
revolutionary where that in the original
we both thought jesse was a guy oh yeah
so in like I'm sorry this one we're like
Oh Jesse was a girl this all died we
decided a really friendly yeah there's a
moment after you escaped the to make a
reactor in the opening where you meet up
on the train looks like the elevators on
another floor and Jesse comes up and
grabs your face and that's like her
first like in the original that's the
main indication you get that she cares
about cloud a lot so I think everybody
got the hots for cloud rhn he's got the
hots for cloud admit it right now there
it is asking it oh yeah
Haley she asked she thought I will never
know Jesse Barrett so over it yes Jordi
you can download it on the PlayStation
Store I was having really weird issues
going directly to the PlayStation Store
on my console I had to go to the link
online and then add it to my download
queue and then go to my console it did
not show up for my download queue I had
to go all the way to all of my purchase
beans and then download it there so
having children will try that out
we are currently investigating whether
they belong to the same group that made
the attempt on your life rest assured
our inquiries will not take much longer
this pump sole purpose is to drain the
planet dry while you sleep
why are you wee while you sit it's here
sucking up Locker
it doesn't rest and it doesn't care
y'all do your lies with Michael Wiz
don't you Marco is the lifeblood of our
world the planet bleeds green like you
and me bleed red the hell you thinks
gonna happen when it's all gone huh
answer me you gonna stand there and
pretend you can't hear the planet crying
out in pain I know you can you really
hear that damn straight I do get help
say that again
yes boss I really do feel like they've
captured like the next five seconds
later the animations of the characters
like when Barrett was talking and the
way he was like movies moving his arms
around while he was talking I was like
that's pretty on point with how was work
yeah
yeah when he's really mad yeah you
listening Merc
one false move well so much for having
cloud do all the fighting there are some
places a sword just can't reach just
fair with him for me would you should
have asked for more money
so how does it feel playing this and
like hearing their voice who's like in
the original it's just text great yeah I
mean they did such a good job of uh you
think they still captured that dialogue
[Music]
for salty is just a pathetic convenient
gonna throw your sword Adam not the man
with the gun
edge
got enough
yeah they look like eyeball plans yeah
that's gonna be fun seeing how they
translate all these wonky monsters into
this beautiful environment it's gonna be
an interesting twist with the reactor
blowing up I'm not sure I like those
read by Nature interesting I'm not sure
what what what he's talking about
exactly cuz but I'm sure you'll notice
the second octave
look what we have here laser security
system great those things will hurt more
than your pride if you're careless
they'll cut you down the size and then
some
yeah figure out the timing of the lasers
then make a move when they'd cycle off
exactly
I'll go first nothing like a little
danger to get the blood pumping I feel
like they have to incorporate some newer
obstacles yeah there's one criticism
I've heard of the game so far it's a
little more padded and the original so
stuff like this
if Barrett definitely got electrocuted I
heard it
oh come on Barrett
yeah it was four instead of three so
cheeky
she's like a proud mother oh that's what
you're talking okay I'll wait and Sunday
it's there
we
keep it together
give it all you've got
can we knock it down again Thank You
Richie
I think this part is cool
youth stuff one person and then pop over
to the next character and keep slicing
them up
give me some Marvel infinite Bible that
sparks the one who asked the
[Music]
soldier first class
I mean your name
that's our target the reactor core gotta
set the bomb at the bottom
I don't know why that's so satisfying
like sliding down the ladder
Barrett went back on the ladder with you
all right more eyeball dudes
[Music]
I think it's kind of cool that they went
such a drastically different direction
because the original is already great
its original right so they're like well
we don't have to worry about that one -
it's already set in stone so they have a
little bit of freedom to do something
different because they know they already
have the first one pretty down packed
so maybe they'll like this one more than
the original actually because how does
this game feel in terms of combat combat
ask hustle and what's up hustle walk a
bit I like it a lot I haven't been doing
too much of it yet but once I get the
system down I was walking between
characters and assigning them abilities
to use and then switching back to
someone else that's actually gonna be
pretty
they're very flashy very satisfying very
weighty we feel though every fitness
clubs or
Brandon says this style of game got me
into Kingdom Hearts heck yeah
this combat style which is I've seen
like in more and more games recently see
if little stamp really can bite the hand
that feeds do the honors and it proved
to me you're the man t4 says you are
that you're one of us never said I was
I'm just here for the paycheck I'm just
here so I won't get fined
what's wrong they showed more of the
flashbacks in the original when he had
those moments right actual scenes
also here's your choice 20 minutes every
minute and funny we definitely gotta go
20 pretty cocky agent Frank I ain't
eunuch no I believe in
cloud at all
we fight this thing
Oh
[Music]
bill DS we barely smashed the damn thing
didn't I tell you you know you take
whatever you want just do
[Music]
Oh scoop all good Barrett's got your
back slow going on live dislike
yeah
blink says the music is great it really
is so what's your brilliant
or go down in flames
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
Klaus is struggling over there
their little band
that's talking so then he says I haven't
started the demo yet but I saw plastic
as an option under difficulty what does
classic you
nice clock
now's our chance give it everything
you've got
[Music]
[Applause]
we're using is
do your thing
single fan hi from Georgia and also
saying a fully seen old gameplay of the
original and I'm loving these graphics
so much for real I could definitely get
behind that honestly I have that same
notion when Kingdom Hearts 3 came out
like this looks so good and it feels
really good to play the story wasn't for
me but everything else is
that makes me really excited for this
to do something about these wounds deal
with that
[Music]
he's such a brute he's like I'm tired of
these barriers
they're painted here
I got
we're drying their data for now
hit it hard and fast
[Music]
say cover behind that debris
[Music]
mark says the symbol was amazing played
the original order lunch when I was a
kid and I can't wait for lunch I like
seeing you know lifelong fans being
really excited about this I feel like
it's easy to be a hater about it but
more content for your favorite games
can't be upset about that
[Music]
hey loser take cover already
[Music]
go who wears the Jesse and all this
shoot chill and she's enjoying the show
Oh
[Music]
we might have an effort
very like I need a break
don't you
find cover and hunker down
very get over here
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yo thanks for tuning
a bit low on the volume for me I know
it's the microphone or a it's not Knicks
ball I promise
it just has to be all up in the personal
space for the volume to work
damnit we gotta take it out we're
screwed
[Music]
[Music]
he's hurt
got a heal up
[Music]
he's almost done though everyone's got
to use their algebra boys funny guy
exactly
yeah it is
yeah
the ball
yeah it's happening I started and he
started to fight we'd be in trouble
damn thing Suja how it's done
come on we've got to move loke one of my
favorite things became today is how CMAs
how seamlessly they put like the
cutscene into putting you back in the
gameplay I love it so much
Kingdom right through they did that
really well too
evil fantasy seven so that's actually a
challenging first boss buy it yeah it's
pretty cool
[Music]
well you still get daddy's over there
LASIK real quick it would have been if
they weren't in the game but I was with
the glamper dream
[Music]
you okay
[Music]
my hero hey we'll link up over there
look after jr. come this way
should lead us straight severity
my favorite RPG of all time
I feel like I haven't played that many
to be honest someone go ahead and fake
[Music]
so steps when I play it I played all of
them I even played the final mixes
ellipsis yeah one two and three and then
one point five and two point five and I
need to go back and play the other like
side ones without like a keyboard those
are the ones I need to play I bought the
whole bundle on Christmas and then they
put it on sale yeah
[Laughter]
soldier boy cool it
[Music]
the game finder likes how we always
imagine it says yes
one of the first games I play
I feel like when we were younger and you
plays these games we were so fascinated
by it
yeah it's like what our imaginations
probably made of the game when we first
played it up yo Barry it was just rain
and friends
Carson played when he was 10 can't
believe a sec 23 years two kisses OH
yeah
deal with that
[Music]
I'm shocked
[Music]
is that it
we still need to get out of here
yeah you have plenty of time
I think this is cool because it's too
like completely different styles I can
see how some people you know they might
not want the hack in the flat part
because there is a little bit of like a
skill silly behind that compared to you
like strategy skill of just sticking
with the Wrightsville on your print
stuff like that with the turn base
it would be cool if they had a mode
where like you know they have easy
normal classic and then like I don't
know super classic where it was just
turned based that might be a lot to
develop which is why I'll never be a
developer because I'll have these crazy
ideas and my game will be in development
for 24 years
[Music]
I when I was playing through my
playthrough he's just saving and I was
like that is really cool
awesome shoutout
[Music]
these Baldo dudes are some super classic
yeah I guess
Oh to the cloud of
whoo these shocked rubric need the relax
[Music]
spread your robots treating cup can't
wait to see the other boss fights yeah
that's all stinking to them like this is
how we're certain I can only imagine how
some of these possibly
I wonder if lots of run away from that
monster near like the chokobo farm yeah
yeah you're gonna cry
Kessie the time went straight down to
three seconds no matter like how far
along
[Music]
sir
[Music]
there's an app for that
destroy the reactors there's an app
[Music]
come on come on
yeah you guys the demo is out now on the
PlayStation Store for free 399 so yeah
go ahead and download it
hop on
[Music]
I remember back in the day when my
parents first got me an Xbox 360 it
needs to make it a point to download
like every single demo I clean the
likely be the first to know
you smooth okay that was cool
all right come on
[Music]
it really puts the story in a little bit
of a different perspective when you get
this much visuals compared to the first
one see that too
Hale a real
[Music]
and now I'm going to murder these fools
with your flour on let's go
yeah I haven't seen as many like
choice-making options with dialogue in
this demo boom demo completed that's
pretty great
and of course
and there we go that is the end of the
demo I'm kind of curious to see how thee
oh you know of course shameless plug hey
now which emerge in would you like to
purchase we already know you had a great
old time no no alright maybe another
time maybe what comes out so maybe we
should try the classic mode since I did
see some interest in the chat about the
classic mode it says the player
controlled character will attack and
defend automatically allowing you to
focus on executing commands the battle
difficulty is the same as easy
womp-womp so you can't switch back and
forth from character to character yeah I
think you should be able to okay it's
just I'm not gonna be able to move cloud
or bear it around they're just gonna
automatically walk up to each enemy and
then I'm going to choose I'm gonna
choose whether I want them to do with
their special attacks or spells in the
chat is sold he said take my money yeah
seriously even if even if reviews call
this like the worst game of all time I'm
probably still gonna get it just yeah
exactly I mean I went to myself into the
game - I didn't get Kingdom Hearts 3 for
a whole year and the whole entire year I
heard nothing about how bad that game
was by so bottom anyways and I still
played it and I still got the DLC stuff
like that whatever you guys like you
guys should play
[Music]
check out the classic mode
man that guy needs to learn some manners
so I think people in this area haven't
played the original
are you guys planning on getting this
because you think it looks really cool
or because you want to experience or
like you feel like an aspect
you might have missed out on the train
for some around
pop it on there now I kind of feel like
there's a little not only is there
pressure as a person who plays like and
I've never played it before because I
feel like people judge you
but now there's gonna be added pressure
to play this one again so it's like
recycle
[Music]
[Music]
video game remix remakes are becoming a
lot more entertaining than movie remakes
says Broly which is yeah I would agree
with that
a lot of the remakes we've been seeing
come out like our resins killing it
Oh
[Music]
get down here murk
like very like literally the fifth time
ha who goes there euro
[Music]
oh so he fights while you just pick what
you want yeah you're coming with us
nice and easy don't think
[Music]
whoa interesting I'm really curious to
see how the bathwater go with this
have fun
[Music]
freeze moving with you go ahead
come on wow this feels kind of cheap
[Music]
that's relatable you know NPCs there is
I'd say seeing some beautiful giant drop
the weapon
you got this yeah what he said
you're coming with us
it gets around it you can still fight
you want to go by
[Music]
Dino prices and Paris ie remakes bring
it all on every last one of them
f zero though where is it at
so what soldier boy steal is he one of
us now he's got balls this what was his
name again
cloud Cloud Strife right and he isn't a
soldier anymore still he's a
professional unlike the rest of us I'm
glad to have him this is a one-time gig
when it's done we're done
we enjoy a movie
notice first guess I'm not
[Music]
come on nobody's do something this crazy
just for money they may not think you're
a true believer but you know what I feel
interested you better be worth the money
every last demo played it twice run our
second run through here ourselves
checking out the classic mode or what I
like to call the hacker mode
remember
the Xbox 360
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're a boy original I realize that I
guess in my mind since all the
characters we're trying to chippy ladies
when you're playing I really thought
like this whole group of people were a
lot younger that's right not like oh
they're definitely all grown adults and
just because they were in to be born
does that mean that they were children
[Music]
[Music]
others
[Music]
guys definitely played the Final Fantasy
games I have played I played in the
completely wrong order
I played final fantasy xi for a little
while which was nothing like the other
Final Fantasy as I played it cuz I had
group of people who were really into it
they helped me get into it play notes
like friendship and bonding and then I
played found penske 9 won a game of
blitzball Lestrade it was like the
greatest thing world and then I
let's go this is we played on normal the
first time
hey wait that's how fast he went through
it that you almost made
[Music]
with uh soldiers may attack on command
but I hit any good guard dogs to that
you've seen a few reactors so how do we
get to the bridge above Makos storage
ain't holding out on me are you
stamp scared to fight two-handed fat him
or is he a loyal though dog
have it your way mutt we can do this
with you or we can do this without you
different reactor different layout
depends when it was built never seen one
like this but I'll manage Donnie says
would this be a good way to enter into
the Final Fantasy world if you have
never done or anything
bigs will have the door open soon that's
a really good question I don't know I
mean it depends what's final fantasy
experience
no that's why
I feel like it's gonna be a great way to
catch up the world of final fantasy
about on par with how I feel about
Kakarot Jack Bellamy pack dry and
catching up with the storyline of
bageshwar I'm about on that same cut it
out I got this place covered well what
are you waiting for it's a good thing I
know someone who can get us the
passcodes City no one else that commands
will talk to us but what can you do and
we're good
careful in there there's definitely
nothing wrong with us
classic mood I'm really curious how it's
gonna play when a we're in the boss
fights
if you really thought right it's not
really my business but are you guys
close t5i
yeah ferret so over it
these sewer rats appear to call
themselves avalanche sir
we are currently investigating whether
they belong to the same group that made
the attempt on your life rest assured
our inquiries will not take much longer
this pump sole purpose is to drain the
planet dry while you sleep why are you
wee while you sit it's his [ __ ]
unlock oh it doesn't rest and it doesn't
care you do realize what micro is don't
you Marco is the lifeblood of our world
the planet bleeds green like you and me
bleed red there you thinks gonna happen
when it's all gone huh
answer me you gonna stand there and
pretend you can't hear the planet crying
out in pain I know you can you really
hear that damn straight I do get help
hon face exactly I could picture clouds
Twitter timeline right now I'd worry
less about the planet and more about the
next five seconds save the screaming for
later
lassic
our lives on the line now yeah he'll
take out the turrets for you probably
only said womp womp about classic being
uneasy because I wanted to try classic
on Normal difficulty it's not because
well I think I'm over having cloud do
all the fighting there are some yeah or
there's memory let you play that mode on
different difficulties horrific I mean
it would make more sense it just stay
there waiting for me would you
because I'm sure there's only so much I
can like handle while you're maneuvering
the other we'll see we'll see we got
like a month in some change
it hadn't been delayed it would have
been me maybe that's why they put the
demo gonna throw your sword at the man
with the gun
I'm okay and I like it I'm telling you
flat out of Twitter need to get Kemp
it's got to hold it down for the squad
[Music]
oh yeah I forgot they're dying faster
shoot I know when I play through it on
normal the turrets on the top we're just
lasering the heck out of me
look what we have here laser security
system great those things will hurt more
than your pride if you're careless
they'll cut you down to size and then
but I'm guessing you've done this kind
of thing before yeah
then make a move when they cycle off
exactly I'll go first nothing like a
little danger to get the blood pumping
nothing like little danger keep those
baby blues of yours on me
not too shabby you're doing good filter
oh the patterns were different on those
ones see I think
pretty easy right nice job Chloe
okay the last thing I've got you
yeah the patterns were different to you
that's interesting most times I feel
like they don't change stuff like that I
just change like how smart or beefy yeah
we rush it we die is that right as a man
with a Gatling gun for an art I think
he's allowed to call this
[Music]
[Music]
listen let's you go back and forth
between them to like if you do want to
start attacking on your own you can but
you don't have first I think people who
like plays the first one a lot will
probably prefer this mode so that they
don't have to deal with the combat stuff
but if you're at Kingdom Hearts been
like me so you just want to mash buttons
all day
oh man I'm really curious how this game
plays on like the hardest difficulty
that's our target
the reactor core gotta hit a bomb at the
bottom
oh yeah
this is the speed
[Music]
animations still slow down when you
write an inbox
I thought since it fit like a tax by
itself it might not like the slow down
version that's like the slow down
pressure is just there so you can at
least have a little bit of time to pick
the options UI because I feel like
that's something I'm stealing hearts I
kind of like it sometimes
I just noticed our eyeballs are rolling
around a little bit for a few frames no
the eyeballs from the monsters the
summons are gonna be cool that I want to
see the summons I saw they had the
chocobo one in the trailer
John says classic mode would be way too
easy I don't think it'll be too easy if
they have more than one difficulty if
they're more the one difficulty then I
think it'll be fine a million
difficulties all right little step
really can bite the hand that feeds go
on
do the honors prove to me you're the man
t4 says you are that you're one of us
never said I was
I'm just here for the Paycheck Pikachu
yeah yeah I just
they go confused eyes what's wrong I'm
fine what about the timer you'll call
oh so last time you said we were talking
yeah let's see what he says this time
with that long enough for you so
[Music]
hey how do we fight this
it's got reinforced armor plating but
the internals can be overloaded
lightning magic
the computer blocks all this by itself
[Music]
we've barely scratched a damn thing
didn't I tell you to use magic
a barrier
system before so what's your brilliant
genius
or go down in flames
yeah it's so good when I was trying to
black when I was playing my renter I
could not do that I mean I think that
was gonna happen regardless because it
needs to teach you how to like save your
friend
don't just stand there help me out damn
it
got to be a way to break through now get
it hearted trash
I feel like low-key nothing zoldifen
like playing an RPG that tells you how
much damage you're doing you just need
one one would why do I like
why is it nothing in there don't want to
be hit by that laser
take cover behind that debris
sit down yeah the a Tiberius was like
nah forget this cover I'm running
believe ya
[Music]
find cover and hunker down
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
please though and fasters with the first
this is the speed run super speed
yeah
the ball
[Music]
I just wanted to hear what Barrett was
gonna say on the other damn thing Suja
how it's done
come on we've gotta move
I mean cloud was being about it
this whole time
Sephiroth in the chat ha said
then why don't I see this on PSN so I
had problems with downloading this this
morning to I had to go on to your place
using a website on my computer find the
item add it to my download queue then go
on to my console go into your library go
through all of your purchase games and
then download it from there I couldn't
find it on the console dashboard when I
was trying to download it from the
website it was not adding it to my
download queue so that was the only way
I could figure out how to download it
for my console if you guys are having
issues finding the get the demo in the
store maybe try
I'm doing
so in the original this part was
optional right like it was something we
just had to know to go pick her up
because she was like on the other side
somewhere look after Jessie come this
way this route should lead us straight
to Barry
[Music]
hold on if I get these two potions
roleplay
yes so much time
shut up and climb no rude I wouldn't
kick him off of this over the ladder
right there
vigorous soldier boy
they're like maybe we put in the
subtitles the wording on cats
it won't come
[Music]
easy-peasy
oh yeah the ball Doughboy okay that's
interesting
no [ __ ] I thought they were just gonna
make them like replace them all together
oh yeah cuz there's no turret okay good
good I was
[Music]
worried that all the monsters we were
gonna see oh there they are I want to
see how much less or more annoying than
or equal annoying
yeah the pattern
take a take left hit all done
do it
wild with the defense over there
I got this
[Music]
No
take bleep the ability yeah maybe get
hit out of it you use here your bar and
you don't get this move to come out
right on time
[Music]
Jack James just finished his playthrough
he said it's amazing but yes you know
this the demo is out now so hop on it
like the carrion demo
which is like this 8-bit you're like the
horror monster and you gotta like go
through all the tunnels meet everybody
and kill them pretty fun I love demos
demos are awesome
yes Malcolm join us download this demo
hits print to see
[Music]
you play this for the first time you
like can you walk
believe me you'd be the first to know
I'll take that as a yes
[Music]
okay that was pretty cool
all right come on it's like the first
time we started seeing being like the
you know evil and tried to crack
letting the guard down
yeah in the original they don't really
show this right they just you talk to a
lot of the people in the town and
everyone's talking about it they're like
oh my goodness lay flat in the head
pretty much to see the reactor explode
and then it comes to
but this one gives you like the lay of
the land like people driving in sudden
hole alright you guys ended our second
run right on time hope you guys enjoyed
the stream and enjoyed checking out
what's the demo has to offer and what we
can expect to see in a little over a
month time when the official remake has
been released be sure to tune back every
single weekday right here at 2 p.m.
Pacific time you want to watch more
GameSpot live where we're playing the
latest agree this and a bunch of other
stuff in between but thank you guys so
much happy Monday and have an amazing
week look at my boy
[Music]
you